When knitting points or starting
with just a few little stitches.
We're sometimes instructed to cast on
those stitches and then increase to form
the point.
Using a cast on rag and ravel cord makes
this process easier than just casting on
2-4 stitches and hoping that they
knit correctly on the first row.
With the rag, you can hang a weight
and ensure that the cast on knits well.
Pull out the instructed number of needles.
I like my crochet cast on rags, but you
can use the edge of a swatch or a small
piece of knitting.
Anything you have laying around.
Manually knit a raw forever cord, hang a
small weight, and then cast on with your
garment yarn.
I'm using a e-wrap cast on here.
Now that you have a little weight in
place, you can knit that first row and
start increasing as
instructed in your pattern.